you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve ce gaz mode sur un nouveau mode
menon bombers comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est comme bomberman mais avec des
melons qui explose sinon c'est un peu
nul quoi serait finalement un marchand
de fruits simulator j'espère que ça vous
plaît à caen tellement là directeur donc
direction on s'en fout j'ai ramassé plus
de bonus de vitesse alors c'est bien je
peux faire quatre fois le tournoi van
mais pour tuer des gens et plus personne
mais elle c'est clair t'as vu ils
tiraient en l'air comme eu des silences
gérons puissance riant mais où je suis a
beaucoup d'élus cas je fais mal
absolument personne espèce de lâche
rester beaulieu des bonus puisque des
bonus ta gueule non je n'ai jamais là la
pièce moi je focus celui qui est au
dessus de moi c'est me calloway spa au
mascaret mika je vais bloqué à bien
jouer avec l'optique mondiale attends tu
tapes un jésuite fait amicale j'arrive
non non j'adore quand il fera cette voix
douce à temps il ya un chat qui me
suffit de voir une porte mais casser je
vous la portez ocha promets moi qui ne
suis pas trop mal de moi c'est non je
marche pas je me bats avec le mec qui
faisait des chansons bon ben je vais
rochât
michael moore michael est mort
j'ouvrirai star du mois prochain
qu'as tu fait 4 à rien car il attend il
a trop géré ouais ok mais je me suis
perdu [ __ ] tu t'es monter la pression
il bossait incroyable alors mégalo ouais
ouais
alors il a pas de chien je voulais te
tuer on n'a pas parlé de la mort à moi
on n'a pas dit que cela tienne mika
bonchamp qu elle était pas mal avant que
tu avais acheté j'ai tué quelqu'un
pardon ah oui c'est mikado excuse-moi
coco coco tu peux envoyer le cas
attention ça joue rapide du côté hugo
oui ça joue sajou voix contre
il a fait peur ce qui nous place et
fassent tuer je viens avec volé quoi
t'as fait quoi tartan du cac est en
panne milan palerme lasserre regard le
maïs est bloquée et remettre debout
parce qu'il faudrait que la femme fêtée
en fait
regardez la halle et hué lou tous tous
ensemble tigers a traversé les les
cubains c'est pourquoi traverser vécu
mais que c'était trop chou des
schizophrènes c'est sûr c'était l'eau
l'angle du du mur et je me suis pris et
gt gt décédé
je t'ai fait de la guerre mon gars
genève est un petit marché quand tout
d'un coup un grand vainqueur [ __ ] les
mecs votre esprit compétitif est
ressorti conjoint c'est incroyable de
quoi vous a jamais vu les observe et
lacroix les vestes en sur le melon il en
est mort mon gars tu pas ni à temps mais
qu'a t il quelque chose
ouais nan parce que j'ai vu un point où
je me suis dit mais après je laisse ça
fait trop de buts qu'on joue une place
mais non mais non énorme mais si mais si
les juges
adjé luc à athus l'étape du cap est ce
que je dis c'est un gros gars ce
pourquoi mon pépère d'avoir maille ou
chat a marché sur les melons ou quoi
c'est le cas ça va [ __ ] le maquereau
je suis là tous les voyous du monde
le câble capot c'est cool dans ces cas
là tu me casses te plait ça le haut mais
non mais j'étais derrière murray alors
là alors là arrêt sur images ah oui est
allé sur élevage rewind on porte plainte
je te regarde si mika
oh non non tu montes
l'arcep a enregistré avec capture à
beugin mais non allez c'est pas gagné
mais cac april aura le même score que
moi il ya un gros problème quoi très
longtemps de gagner je sais plus quand
on s'appelait en fait j'ai tué mes
voyages
mais j'étais à côté de toi mais c'est
tout c'est tout ce qui n'était pas
choqué je trouvais ça normal
je trouve ça normal ah mais je suis
monté je suis monté montée bon tonneau
je veux finir sur une victoire salut
c'est pas parce que je te laisse
également à les saluer c'était soir
boris alors les mecs j'ai satellite
première qu'est ce que je casse
c'est un message de quelqu'un quelqu'un
probablement cible sur son ordinateur
d'avoir un bonus où ça se passe comment
tiens en voici en voilà
alors ça va pas marcher de coller en
fait j'ai gagné j'ai gagné merci martin
c'est une victoire très honorable aux
agences et sur cette victoire plus
honorables comme ce fut le cas du pays
tous ces mois mais oui on se quitte
j'espère qu'il aura plus si le calme ne
s'était pas me lève de sa frappe en
pleine pousse comme dans une nouvelle
vidéo blablabla blablabla rabbit et
docks iphone 4 tout le monde a pu
[Musique]